[Music]
one two three
[Music]
[Music]
we call it blending if you're blending
right you can't pick out any individual
voices but the soloist
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Izzy Lloyd I am a mechanical
engineering and product design student
at MIT and I'm an alto and the MIT
corollaries I joined freshman fall so
fall 2014 I am now the old crusty like
his senior these kinds of things are
like truly the definition of like the
whole is greater than the sum of the
parts
MIT
[Music]
[Applause]
MIT MIT smallest co-ed a cappella group
we invite you all to attend our concert
tomorrow at 3:30 p.m. and as Gary
this is a dedicated time where I just
get to turn my brain off to engineering
and turn it on to art we are a very like
highly sought after group in terms of
like gigs a lot of the times charity
functions will have us Institute events
will have us a lot and the money goes
towards like recording albums going on
tour competing in competitions we all
get in formation for the next song wall
Caitlyn announces us it's hard when we
step out of MIT because you've got all
of these other brilliant acapella groups
across the world who the best ones are
made up of students who like their major
is music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
tones are so excited to have you all
here and breathe big crazy auditorium
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
being able to step into this space where
we all create this beautiful thing
together just like totally resets sort
of the way I'm thinking and the way I'm
feeling
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]